The religion of Islam significantly influenced
knowledge-making in the greater Mediterranean
and western Asian world.
Islamicate scholars—meaning people influenced
by Islamic civilization, regardless of their
religious views—gave us terms such as “algebra,”
“azimuth,” “algorithm,” “alcohol,”
“alkali,” and “alembic.”
We’ll dive into Islamic medicine and philosophers
such as the great Persian polymath Ibn Sina
in future episodes.
For now, let’s explore the beginnings of
Islamicate natural philosophy.
[Intro Music Plays]
Islamicate power expanded rapidly after the
Prophet Muhammad’s death in CE 632.
What began as one vast Arab-governed state
soon fractured into two spheres of political
influence: a western one centered in southern
Spain, with a capital at Córdoba, and an
eastern one including the great cities of
northern Africa as well as Arabia and Mesopotamia.
This eastern empire, the highly urbanized
Abbasid Caliphate,
existed in some form, increasingly fragmented,
from 750–1517.
The Abbasid Caliphate was a crossroads or
trading zone for Persian, Indian, and Byzantine
cultures, as well as for the religions of
Islam, Judaism, Christianity, and Zoroastrianism.
Many languages flourished across the Abbasid
Caliphate, as they did in the Emirate of Córdoba.
This blend of cultures and belief systems
made early Islamicate science cosmopolitan—that
is, generally inclusive in character.
A high literacy rate thanks to Islam’s focus
on the Qur’an meant that many people—well,
noble men, at least—could study natural
philosophical texts.
Further, Islam-the-religion called on its
adherents to treat others as equals, helping
make Islamicate knowledge production more
egalitarian.
And ongoing support by pious philanthropists
including heads of states allowed Islamicate
polymaths to study natural phenomena systematically.
Baghdad, the first Abbasid capital, was founded
by its second caliph, al-Mansur, in 754.
A sprawling metropolis quickly grew up around
the original, carefully planned city.
And Baghdad became the largest urban area
in the world by 930, with a population of
one million.
Key for our story today: Baghdad housed the
Bayt al-Ḥikmah or House
of Wisdom.
This great library grew out of al-Mansur’s
private collection, which he opened up to
visiting scholars, including delegations from
India.
Al-Mansur’s successor, Caliph al-Rashid, carried on this tradition.
Al-Rashid also supported the Translation Movement,
which we’ll get to shortly.
But first, let’s reflect on his rule as
a great example of the cosmopolitan character
of the early Abbasids.
Charlemagne sent a mission from France to
al-Rashid’s court in 799 with gifts.
So in 802, al-Rashid sent Charlemagne an embassy
including an elephant named Abul-Abbas and
a water clock that featured clockwork knights
who emerged once per hour.
You could see the elephant’s journey as
one origin of veterinary science: the Abbasid
diplomats kept the elephant healthy walking
from India to Baghdad to France, and it lived
for years after in captivity.
And, to the Franks, the water clock was simply
mind-blowing, something they’d never even
imagined!
But it was al-Rashid’s successor, Caliph
al-Maʾmūn, who in 832 refounded
the House of Wisdom specifically as an international
center for translation and research.
Al-Maʾmūn was involved in the House’s
daily operations, and he sponsored knowledge
production programmatically, inspiring his
successors to do the same.
By 850, the House of Wisdom had become the
largest library in the world.
Al-Maʾmūn sponsored families of scholar–translators
to bring useful texts into Arabic from Greek,
Chinese, Sanskrit, Persian, and Syriac.
This should be known as the “Useful Texts
into Arabic Movement” but, for some reason,
is called the Translation Movement instead.
This movement began with Persian texts concerning
astrology and astronomy.
Remember that, across the ancient and medieval
worlds, astronomy was the study of the heavens,
and astrology the study of the influence of
heavenly bodies on earthly matters.
While both were studied, astrology was seen
as more useful.
After texts about the stars, the translators
moved onto others.
To feed this program, al-Maʾmūn sent emissaries
to collect Greek scientific manuscripts from
the Byzantines—and began demanding them
as loot in war.
The Translation Movement lasted from roughly
750–950.
By 950, virtually every Greek scholarly text
had been translated multiple times, and the
libraries were brimming.
Many translators of Baghdad particularly fell
for the works of Aristotle.
One of the greatest Islamicate philosophers,
Ibn Rushd, is sometimes called
“The Commentator,” meaning the number-one
Aristotle fan.
To this day, more classical Greek commentaries
on Aristotle may be available in Arabic than
English!
Why was Caliph al-Maʾmūn so into the Persian
and Greek science?
For one, supporting translations was a sign
of civic status, and a worthy cause.
Al-Maʾmūn also saw scientific translation
as highly practical.
For example, a better understanding of astronomy
led to more accurate official timekeeping
for mosques.
And improved geographical knowledge helped
more accurately align prayers to Mecca.
The Translation Movement also fostered a strong
appreciation for reasoned thought, at least
among the ruling and scholarly classes.
This rubbed off on religious philosophy, giving
rise to the school of mu‘tazilism.
Mu‘tazila such as al-Maʾmūn believed that
rationalism could be used to understand both
the physical world and God.
They brought the Greek tradition of reasoned
debate about the nature of the cosmos into
an Islamicate social context, looking beyond
a literal reading of the Qur’an for sources
of knowledge.
In fact, places of learning under the Abbasid
Caliphate included observatories, hospitals,
and public libraries, as well as mosques and
madrasas, or Islamic colleges.
Madrasas were critical centers of knowledge
transmission.
There were thirty in Baghdad in the 1200s,
and one hundred and fifty in Damascus by 1500.
Each madrasa had its own library full of paper
books.
Paper had been introduced to western Asia
from China, and paper factories appeared in
Samarkand, Baghdad, Cairo, Morocco, and finally
in Spain by 1150.
While they were religious centers, madrasas
were also places where students could learn
law as well as Greek natural philosophy, including
logic and arithmetic, astronomy, and astrology.
Abbasid scholars didn’t merely translate
foreign writers.
In translating the texts, these polymaths
wrote commentaries on them, comparing, summarizing,
and analyzing them.
Even when motivated by utilitarian concerns,
the work of careful reading and comparison
led many scholars to pursue new questions
in natural philosophy.
For example, observatories arose throughout
the Islamicate world.
Al-Maʾmūn built two observatories, one in
Baghdad and another outside Damascus.
At these sites, scholars refined astronomical
handbooks, called zīj, that helped
fix prayer times.
In fact, by the late ninth century, Islamicate
polymaths such as Abu Maʿshar,
the famous Persian physician al-Razi —whom
we’ll meet again soon—and the Indian-influenced
al-Biruni were even proposing
heliocentric models of the solar system.
Their theories went against Aristotle but
with observed data!
In geography, Islamicate scholars extended
Ptolemy’s system.
Our scientific hero today, Caliph al-Maʾmūn,
commissioned a measurement of earth’s circumference
that was pretty amazing: two groups ventured
into the desert, finding a specific location
by following the stars.
One group walked north and the other south,
tracking the stars for one degree.
They counted their paces.
Then they walked back, remeasured, averaged
the measurements… and multiplied by 360
to derive a circumference of 24,480 miles.
The modern measurement?
24,901—less than 2% more accurate than the
one made by al-Maʾmūn’s team.
And don’t get me started on astrolabes!
You know—mechanical devices used for measuring
incline by astronomers and navigators?
To determine the position of celestial bodies
in the night sky?
The ones Islamicate astronomers improved by
adding the azimuth, or direction of compass
bearing?
And then merged with armillary spheres, or
models of the entire cosmos constructed from
rings and hoops that revolved on their axes,
around 900?
And then improved into geared mechanical astrolabes
in 1235?
I’m looking at you, Abi Bakr of Isfahan!?
MEANWHILE—back at the House of Wisdom…
In addition to translation and improvement
on Greek natural philosophy, scholars were
also innovating in new realms.
In mathematics, medieval Islamicate scholars
focused on arithmetic and algebra.
They adopted the number zero and the “Arabic”
decimal-style numerals from India, using them
so much that they became known to us as, well,
Arabic.
They also developed trigonometry.
One example of this work in particular jumps
out: in 820, at the House, Muhammad ibn Musa
al-Khwarizmi wrote Kitab al-Jabr,
or The Compendious Book on Calculation by
Completion and Balancing, an original manual
of practical math.
Al-Khwarizmi wasn’t the first to work on
algebra, but he set out the general rules
for solving equations that was highly influential
for centuries.
Algebra introduced a theory that treated rational
numbers, irrational numbers, geometrical magnitudes—all
numbers—as similar objects, ready to be
manipulated.
Or, as my dude himself says it: “When I
consider what people generally want in calculating,
I found that it always is a number.”
Mic drop!
This opened up the possibility of exploring
new areas of mathematics such as algorithms,
quadratic equations, and polynomial equations.
Also at the House of Wisdom, thinkers such
as Mohammad Mūsā worked on the basic laws
of physics.
Others focused on optics, performing many
experiments.
And doctors and philosophers trained and traded
works.
But what about the engineers—the scholars
working on technē instead of epistēmē?
The Abbasid state privileged public service
and the interests of the state, focusing on
improving useful arts such as hydraulic engineering
and agricultural science.
The Abbasids used the arch, rather than the
Greek post and lintel system.
And they constructed large dams, waterwheels,
and qanats, or underground channels
to tap groundwater.
Abbasid technology thus resembled that of
the Romans, with craftspeople, not scholars,
typically building actual stuff.
But a few stand-out engineers from this time
period created wonders so—er—wondrous,
that they deserve a little attention from
ThoughtBubble:
In 850, at the House of Wisdom, the Banū
Mūsā brothers—Mohammad,
just mentioned, and Ahmad and Hasan—wrote
The Book of Ingenious Devices:
a compendium of one hundred devices and how
to use them.
This included the earliest programmable machine,
“The Instrument that Plays by Itself.”
Medieval automation, whaaat!?h
And it gets cooler.
In 1206—far from Baghdad, in what is now
Diyarbakır, Turkey—the
polymath al-Jazarī wrote an
even more amazing book on machines: The Book
of Knowledge of Ingenious Mechanical Devices
also covers one hundred machines, with instructions
on how to build them.
Most of these are trick vessels, but others
include water wheels, watermills, a giant
water clock, elephant- and castle-shaped clocks,
fountains improving upon designs by the Banū
Mūsās, a candle clock, and musical automata.
Al-Jazarī even designed a water-powered,
perpetually-playing flute!
How did these devices work?
Well, it helped that al-Jazarī invented the
camshaft, which would make it into Europe
by the 1300s, an early version of the crankshaft,
and the segmental gear.
You can look up how these work online, but
the point is: our modern world runs on them,
and this guy figured them out in medieval
times.
That is so.
Dang.
Cool.
But the coolest of al-Jazarī’s inventions
were his full-on automata—medieval robots.
He made humanoid machines including one that
could serve water or tea.
He made a flushing toilet with a nearby servant,
who refilled the basin when flushed.
And the pièce de résistance: al-Jazarī
constructed a four-piece robot band that floated
on a lake, entertaining party guests.
The music?
Most likely programmable, using tiny pegs
and levers.
Thanks Thought Bubble!
We could spend several more episodes on science
in the early Islamicate world.
And we will come back to some of the people
and themes mentioned today.
There’s a common understanding of the history
of medieval Eurasia and North Africa long-held
by many English speakers is just plain wrong:
instead of a “dark age” defined by conflicts
between Muslims and Christians who didn’t
understand one another, we encounter urban
centers of trade and knowledge exchange populated
by natural philosophers with a keen desire
to build upon earlier insights regardless
of their origins.
Next time—we’ll build many cities and
one very long canal in the rich Middle Kingdom,
China.
Crash Course History of Science is filmed
in the Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney studio in Missoula,
Montana and it’s made with the help of all
this nice people and our animation team is
Thought Cafe.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels like Scishow, Eons, and Sexplanations.
And, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.